I think Japanese pop music will sound
really fast really happy like electronic
music with like high-pitched voices
it'll probably sound like Katy Perry
like Bjork the ice
sounds like a 90s rap group whoa this is
fast oh it's really happy it's really
fun it's kind of like a goofy movie I
just imagine a bunch of people on a
dance floor just sweating this is some
chika workout too and just kill it on
the treadmill
it definitely sound like an American
like country song but like more like
bales in the background beautiful
symphony in the background some piano
it's got everything it's blowing out all
the stops the romance this sounds like
John Denver he's really sad about it
maybe he's asking his dad for a loan
just like you're coming down on some
drugs and your ass is done it really
sounds a lot like Sesame Street I could
picture myself crying to this song I'm
on a game show running down the stairs
to this song pad it's so high-pitched
the song feels like it's a commercial
for liquid soap this is exactly like
Rainbow Road on Mario Kart these are
like sorority girls sitting around
talking about someone being real sassy
it's probably about friendship it's
probably about honesty a
fourteen-year-old girl that's like
trying to get out of the house and get
away from her oppressive parents and
she's like pleading with them but
they're like you're 14 and you sound
like a mouse so we don't trust you
Japanese pop music is delightful it's
very upbeat and it's very fast and it's
very in-your-face it's like you're
inside the circuit board of a new
computer every song is like a hug
they're so positive they're so friendly
it's like a handshake and a wink and a
milkshake
it's everything you want in music